displaced persons camps like these in
nigeria's northeast are still filling up
as boko haram attacks escalate the
recent violence has forced some families
who had earlier went back to their homes
to return to the relative safety of the
camps
president muhammadu buhari has now
replaced his top military commanders
but there is mixed reaction to the news
sunday ishaya says
he fled from mangunu a town repeatedly
targeted by boko haram fighters
the sucked ones have
not improved what we the idps want
what we want is not to repeal the boko
haram but to kill them
not to repel them but to kill them to
finish them at once not to repeat them
again
we are repeating one tear at all the
time that is the reason why we are not
after them
we want somebody that will just degrade
them complete them
whip them away since the beginning of
the year however the military says it
has successfully raided boko haram camps
and beat back several incursions by the
armed group
during renewed air and ground offensive
what does
kashavi to be sincere the outgoing
service chiefs have tried their best
but in some instances their best isn't
enough at all despite the fact that we
are not security experts
but we know that they have failed it's
been
11 years since boko haram launched its
violent campaign in nigeria's northeast
but the am group isn't the only security
concern attacks by other fighters in the
northwest have escalated
despite military operations there armed
robberies and kidnappings for ransom
are on the rise here in the southern
delta region
all theft and other criminal activities
persist in addition
to successionist movement in the east
that refused to go away
all these have kept the military busy
and overstretched
but experts say it's a nigerian strategy
to fight these groups that's not working
globally fighting insurgency is also
70 percent or 80 percent civilian effort
and 20 or 30 percent military effort
they synergize together
they bond together they look at the
problem
of the country secreting the country as
their collective
challenge after more than a decade of
attacks and uncertainty
nigerians want a quick end to the
lawlessness that has forced millions
from their homes
and killed thousands of people for now
there seems to be some goodwill
for the new military leadership but it's
not clear if this will last
if there is an uptick in violence ahmedi
rise
al jazeera potter cut nigeria